what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and if you're looking for the next
Avengers level movie a movie that is
going to be on the same scale as an
Avengers movie the next one we are
getting is actually Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania of course this is not an
official Avengers film however the
writers and the directors of Ant-Man 3
have come out and said that this is
indeed going to be on the level of an
Avengers movie basically meaning that
this movie is going to be huge and it's
going to be extremely important after
all it is going to be introducing us to
the big bad of the Multiverse Saga we
already briefly met one of his variants
of course in the Loki series when we
were introduced to he who remains
however this variant is an actual Kang
the Conqueror variant still in that
conquering phase of his life so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man set out not only for world
domination but multiversal domination so
it would make sense that Ant-Man and the
Wasa quantumania would be a very big
movie and having said that it's now
going to be the longest Ant-Man movie
that's ever been made so far now we're
also going to be talking about when to
expect that next trailer for Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and talking about
Jessica Jones returning to the MCU so
stay put but Fandango has listed Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania's run time at 2
hours and 5 minutes which is a new
record for an Ant-Man film not by much
but still a record nonetheless the first
Ant-Man film comes in at one hour and 57
minutes while the second one Ant-Man and
the WASP comes in at 1 hour and 58
minutes a whopping seven minutes longer
again not much longer but here's what
the director had to say about the scale
of the movie and about how important
this movie is going to be going forward
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I
know a lot of people are already excited
about about this movie but just listen
to what director Peyton Reed has to say
about this movie and Kang the Conqueror
and you're truly going to realize that
Kang is truly a force to be reckoned
with and this movie is going to be huge
in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly he expressed that the previous
Ant-Man films were seen AS Palette
cleansers and he wanted to change that
so in the interview he said people felt
like oh these are fun little palette
cleansers after a gigantic Avengers
movie for this third one I said I don't
want to be the palette cleanser anymore
I want to be the big Avengers movie when
telling him this I metaphorically kicked
in Kevin feige's door and here's where
he gives us some details about what to
expect from Kang the Conqueror in the
film he continues in the interview I
grew up a real Marvel Comics nerd and
there are a handful of antagonists in
the Marvel Comics universe who are
Alzheimer's Loki obviously Dr Doom from
the Fantastic Four and Kang the Kong
conqueror in conversations with Kevin
feige and Marvel it was like I want to
put Ant-Man and wasp up against a really
formidable villain in this movie and so
we're doing King the Conqueror in the
comics King has dominion over time he's
a time traveler his situation is a
little bit different in this movie which
I won't spoil for you but he's someone
while we live very linear lives from
childhood to death Kang doesn't exist
that way it struck me as interesting to
take the tiniest Avengers in some
people's mind maybe the least powerful
Avengers and put them up against the
most powerful force in the Multiverse
now I love that final line where he says
Kang the Conqueror is the most powerful
force in the Multiverse this is why he
is going to be the big bat however we
already know that we are going to see
more than one Kang variant in
quantumania we so far know about at
least two and one of them is going to be
asking Ant-Man for his help to take down
the other because remember the true
multiversal war that happened before in
the past was between a bunch of
different variants of Kang it wasn't a
bunch of Avengers fighting each other it
was literally just variants of King and
in this Comet that he makes where he
says he's not going to spoil the movie
This is actually what he is referring to
he is referring to one of the variants
of Kang that we're going to be
introduced to in Quantum Mania you see
in this interview what he said although
he doesn't reveal it because of course
spoilers he is actually talking about
two kings one of them is the one he's
talking about where he says Kang has
dominion over time he's a time traveler
but then he is actually talking about a
different one where he says his
situation is a little bit different in
this movie that is because as we know
from the trailers one variant of King is
stuck stuck inside of the quantum realm
and he needs Ant-Man to steal something
for him to get out we've seen this power
source in the trailer before and this is
most likely what king the Conqueror
needs to power his time chair his time
chair in the comics is pretty simple
it's how he travels through time we get
a little glimpse of this in the Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania trailer but we
also get a glimpse at the other Kang the
king that is essentially in charge of
the quantum realm we see the huge
Quantum City we see the huge Army that
King the Conqueror has we see all of the
advanced technology and we see what
seemed to be different portals going out
of the quantum realm these are what Kang
the one in charge most likely uses to
travel through different points in the
universe and not just our universe but
of course the Multiverse so there's
going to be a main Kang and then the
King on the sidelines asking Ant-Man for
help so essentially Ant-Man is already
going after the big bad that literally
The Avengers are going to go after in
the King Dynasty and then the
multiversal heroes are then going to go
after in secret Wars so in this film
it's up to our tiny little Ant-Man
family to take on probably the biggest
and baddest villain that we've ever seen
in the MCU so far and hopefully we get a
better look at Kang in the next trailer
that has come we're actually getting a
special clip trailer Monday the 9th this
will be on ESPN and Marvel has already
marketed this as a new exclusive look
trailer like I said it's debuting on
ESPN at some point in time during the
national college football championship
game that's going to start at 7 30
Eastern time if you need to convert that
into your own time just type it into
Google and of course it's going to be
put on YouTube probably exactly at the
same time as it releases that's what
Marvel Studios has typically been doing
so Ant-Man 3 is going to be a huge movie
on the same level as an Avengers movie
which is just awesome it's about time
that Ant-Man and the wasp and the rest
of the family are getting the credit and
attention that they deserve and to top
it all off like I mentioned in the
beginning we do have some news about
Jessica Jones possibly returning to the
MCU now we've been hearing rumors about
this possibly happening for some time
now we've even gotten some reports from
some insiders and since Charlie Cox has
returned as Daredevil we now know that
it is actually possible for some of
these Defenders from the Netflix series
to return and now actress Kristen Ritter
who of course plays Jessica Jones
herself has posted some pictures to
Instagram of her training with a
daredevil shirt on this is very
interesting as I'm sure most Marvel
actors know what they're doing when they
share photos like this wearing that type
of shirt it's also very interesting to
note that Daredevil born again which she
is rumored to appear in starts filming
next month so is she training for a
cameo and Daredevil born again right now
or possibly another project such as the
echo series which Daredevil is confirmed
to be in as well the timing certainly is
very coincidental probably a little bit
more than coincidental since Charlie Cox
has returned as Daredevil D'Onofrio has
returned as Kingpin I'm assuming that
we're going to see cameos from these
other characters as well perhaps not all
of them but I would love to see Jessica
Jones return which it kind of does look
like is going to happen and I would love
to see of course Frank Castle The
Punisher of course played by John
Bernthal I don't want it unless he is
going to be playing him but it looks
like there are some very exciting things
coming up in the MCU for those who
thought phase 4 might have been a little
bit Bland the future of Phase 5 and
phase six is looking very very good and
even Beyond because we know that the
X-Men and the Fantastic Four are going
to be really big focuses of phase seven
eight and beyond that as well so drop
some comments down below about how
excited you are for Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania the possibility of Jessica
Jones returning to the MCU or I should
say making her debut in the MCU and of
course Phase 5 and phase six altogether
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news and you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf